どうぞ見ているみんな海に入った回避中には受験生の方もいると思います
もうすぐ夏休み受験生の皆さんは良いよ本格的な受験勉強
で戻せ風の海の日身内ぐらいはね
受験生の皆さんの今日だけは今日だけは次元の事を忘れてみんなの海に行きませんき
ますよー
はい高校3年の受験時代が一番人生で頑張っていましたはじめ社長ですあの受験生の皆
さんもう休めないですよ夏になるともみんな勉強してるのは当たり前なんで今サボると
最も人で負けますかここからは勉強するのが当たり前の戦いになるのであとはいかに
賢く勉強できるか時間を取れるかで勝負が決まりますのでぜひ頑張ってください
ごめんある図形
ガチでだったからさぁ毎回なんですけどあの頃がクリスティさんを思い出すんで受験が
ある人には頑張って欲しいなといつも思ってしまいます肇社長ですとよりで新しい
シャーペンが出ましたもう絶対皆さん知ってると思いますけど知ってるシャーピンの
新型でございますはいこちらきれいな文字が書ける上で別れたわかる人振るとかです
空母の新型くるとがアドバン
ガーンッ
なんか色々ググっ書いてあるね夏風邪からあとはちょっと細かく切っていくんですけど
も普通のプルートだと比べてくるとがエンジンの回転が2倍速になってるらしいです
学生時代フォト使ってはないですけどもサーフィンはたまに使っておりますねあの
やっぱりシャーペン業界というと一応まだくるとかでしょ
写メランキングなくて一応どのてみようマイパクるとか1位ですね資本的にいろんなさ
と見ても降るとかがやっぱり市稲垣なんですけどもうくるとが今まで33ぐらい
いろんなタイプを出してきましたちょっと色持ち合わせてないんですけどもこちら通学
ルートがですねシンプルな普通が来るとがちょっと高められたけども鋭くなってくるの
が早いけれどモデル後くるとかにゃのある下げるの国々が合体したユニアルファゲルの
来るぞがバージョンこの3世にが今まであったんですけ
もまあを持して
いや俺変態おじさんダシャーペイ辺で落ちたんだよもう満を持して進化したくると
分かっていました
これが何を意味してる分かるかみんなそうサーフィン業界が車がトップとトップが新型
のプール店を出すということはまさに時代が変わる瞬間ですよ
はいといったけども咲きだしたんだけどねはい靴が来ると&版でございますえっと
カラーリングが6色ございました
すごいねもう色の展開が多いなんてと細かく見ていきましょうなったくしゃーぺんの
生涯しなさそうなチャンネルなのに急に超えるのがクールですよあれで受験者の皆さん
あのシャーペンだけば
頑張ってる君をずっと見てるからまぁ今回何が大きく変わったのと言いますそれですね
なんかもう凄いきれいに書けるらしいんですよ
最近流行りの神よね防止機構ですね先っぽが折れにくくなってるやつ
基本的にまあ性能としてはくるとまた同じなんですけど萌速ダブルスピードエンジンが
すごい
くるとが何でも頭がトガり続けるかと言いますとクルド園児がちょっと回転し続けて1
階と1階とってするとき
映像を改善するんですけど問題 wp デンジャーになってから18の回転するらしい
ですつまりフィールドエンジンの回転数自体が二倍速くなっているのでまだ買い手は
ないんですけども多分もっととがあるんじゃないかという気はしておりますそしてなん
か金属のパーツがたら血入ったとなぁ
見た目なぜでも見た目ルックスが良くないと林今日のモチベーションは上がりません
からクリーチャーと言ったら水色って水があります
でもこういいな先端が最初しまってるプロジェクションな部分が出てくるというこれで
芯が折れにくいというわけでスエード by sab サーフィン上の消しゴムは
なるべく使いたくないまんでした
はいじゃああーなんか高級か
が筆でエンジンが黒に黄色のロボになっておりますいいなああああか黒にかけて by
だけど僕の方がそれはどこの2色でございます持ってるペンのいるだけでもかなりモチ
ベーションっていうかね気持ちの変化はあるのかなと思っております
ホームページにあっただけなんだけどねちょっとせっかく普通のくるとか持ってるで
見比べてみましょうかそんなみたいな特別大きく変わったわけじゃないんですけども
やはり高級感が出ますね金属パーツが増えたことによってエンジンのバスト部分が少し
短くなっております
はいだけで実際に帰ってみましょう
ああああああ
まぁいつも通りなんですけど
追加いいね米で字が汚くてやはりこの中に注目商品ですけども
鍵をかくほどの中のくるとペインティング覚えていますそのグールドの2倍の速度で
動くのでかなりそうあり続けるわけでございます珍名サーキットが丸くなってるね戸部
続けているとこういうことです鋭さがかなりアップしているわけでございます
[音楽]
なぁでもやっぱりあれですねくると判断の着地した瞬間確信した瞬間のクルトガ
エンジンがどうしてもネジを回さなきゃいけないのでちょっとポイッと
県の浮き沈みする感覚があるんですけどもそれは良い変わらず残っておりますまあこれ
はフルトレンドの白仕方ないことではあるのでまぁなぜしかないと思いますなぜバスず
生きるですねやまこれ結構ありだとこれかなりいいぞ全然昔のくると
の100倍以上ひどい
ひどいはじめ
なんでそんなこといいな僕がやあ
僕がずっといいからダメ
ああああを散っていき3ブラッ
ブーブー jr ああああ
お前なて貴重なこと言うんじゃねぇ
しゃべん作るのにねぇ
[音楽]
どれだけ大変か分かってるのかのようなうん
これは一度もお前たちが必要ないなと言ったことはない
いいかお前 a
人にはな
人それぞれの
アンらはないがいるんだよ
誰が一番だっていいじゃないかって
誰が日れた p じゃないか世界にわー
me
お前らが必要と生が来てがいるかもしれないんだよ
当たればいいんですよ
渡ればいいんだよ
[拍手]
お酒ばいいけどお前が一番最高
[音楽]
me
あっはぁ